so in anticipation to the scheduled
release today's draft is the teams we
want to see the most under the lights in
primetime you've got the trivia question
I'm under the hot light to try to get it
right if I get it ready to get the first
pick what do you got all right well I
think this one's easy I mean this is
like what color is blue day for you it's
unreal the questions they give you here
we go
four teams played six prime time games
last season four teams played six prime
time games most of the NFL name one of
them one of the teams that played six
prime time games see is this a trick did
the Cowboys not play six last year is
this were you trying to leave me I'll
say the Vikings man 100 you're horrible
I just can't believe you didn't get this
your bike you don't know your own team's
prime time games last year
did you know you know what did you lose
six games they didn't lose six games so
they couldn't applied six games in prime
no well they wanted to put them on prime
time but you crapped out Kirk Cousins in
his prime time record so many times that
they decide not to give them six oh no
the correct 49ers Packers Steelers and
Rams 49ers went five and one Packers
were foreign to steelers and rams were
both three and three in prime time so I
knew it wasn't the Cowboys I knew it was
a setup on the Cowboys I just guessed
wrong on that one one of the other teams
that made it yep okay here we go
well I'm gonna uh you know I don't care
that it's it's obvious I'm gonna go with
the Buccaneers I mean come on yes of
course that's who I want to see in
primetime one you know I'm an ex
Buccaneer player it's the team that I
hold dearest to my heart along with the
New York Giants and - you know what it's
can't-miss TV it's Tom Brady and Bruce
Arians and and and Rob Gronkowski and
Adamic ensue and of course Shaquille
Barry I mean there's a lot of household
up and coming stars and already proven
stars on that Tampa Bay football team
and of course we're always interested to
see what you put that many different
cast of characters together on a given
team can it work you know will it work
how long will it take the gel and really
come together
and the fact that you know again they're
in a really good division the NFC South
the Saints in Falcons certainly aren't
gonna be any pushovers
yeah the Bucs are the team I'm most
excited to see yeah that is the obvious
answer and you know for us and I'm for
any football fan if you really are
serious about following the sport the
thing you appreciate about primetime
games is that's the only game that's on
you're not worrying about the other
seven games at 1:00 o'clock Eastern or
the other four games late afternoon you
got one game you can focus on it feels
like a big deal and you really can enjoy
and appreciate what's happening that's
why I'm going with the Packers because
the Packers have accepted whether they
did it intentionally or not this mantle
of potential for dysfunction I want to
see how it plays out this year I want to
study every facial expression of Aaron
Rodgers every sideline communication
with his head coach Matt Lafleur I want
to see what Rodgers does now that they
are putting him in a position where he
feels like they are pulling the train
into the station whether the Train wants
to go into the station or not I think
every Packers game will be fascinating
this year and the bigger the stage the
greater the potential for somebody maybe
blowing a gasket if things don't go well
so put me down for the Packers first
pick your really yeah I mean I'm really
are you sure you sure you get a room for
the Vikings this year I feel like you're
more on Aaron Rodgers bandwagon this
year than ever I'm kind of listening and
these are these are people don't realize
and I let you I let you goose me about
you know fan loyalties and look we got
into this this business because we love
football you played it I mean how you
have you have strong interest I think
now I get more caught up in storylines
and individuals I have people that I
like and even though people think I
don't like Aaron Rodgers I like Aaron
Rodgers and I feel like the Packers have
done him wrong and I think it's a great
story I want to see him do well I want
to see him go out there and have a great
season and have the Packers aim it
either privately or publicly maybe we
shouldn't have drafted a quarterback so
yeah I'm
I think it's very compelling yeah that's
cool that's why I like you you keep it
100 if you don't like something you
speak the truth if you do you speak the
truth too so I've got much respect for
you along along those lines I mean yeah
I hate to do this but like I'm sorry I
mean to me the team I want I want to see
Patrick mahomes the Kansas City Chiefs I
know it's like not a fun pic or like you
know lacks creativity but damn I mean
number 15 in red is the most fun thing
to watch and football for me right now
you know and then you know you add the
fact that I just think they're gonna be
flying high from the Super Bowl win with
the bullseye on their back at the same
time but I think they're welcoming this
I think this is a team that's really
looking to be like a dynasty or make
their mark on history I don't think one
Super Bowl is gonna satisfy the the
appetite of mahomes and Andy Reid and
Tyree kill and Travis Kelce I really
think they're gonna love being the team
with the bullseye on their back this
year I do and I just think with that and
of course just Mahone's becoming a
better and better football player you
know and exciting as he is to me he's
the most fun watching the game right now
him and Aaron Rodgers are can't-miss TV
so you took Rogers and I'll take my
homes next yeah I thought about taking
the Chiefs instead of the Packers and
you're right you want to see the
champions you want to see them on the
big stage you want to watch greatness we
like to witness history right that's one
of the things sports fans love to do
that's why kids who are watching
basketball today are trying to make the
argument LeBron James was better than
Michael Jordan maybe if they're watching
the last dance they feel differently but
we all want to say we had a front-row
seat for something historic and Patrick
mahomes is historic and the more of
those games we can watch in primetime
the more we can say we are witnessing
that kind of history now yes
similar but but different I want to see
the 49ers in primetime because I look
they are a team that's gonna have a
target on their backs from making it to
the Super Bowl last year can they
replicate it will Jimmy Garoppolo rise
to the occasion he's been doubted
rightfully so by virtue of the fact that
he missed Emmanuel Sanders when he was
open with a potential championship throw
at the end of the Super Bowl will
functioned well under the bright lights
or will he crater a little bit will we
see that elaborate Kyle Shanahan running
game that we love to watch the 49ers are
a fun team to watch they have a great
defense it's fun to watch them play
defense it's fun to watch them play
offense will Kyle wear that trucker hat
next year plenty of other questions that
we'll all be satisfied to the maximum if
we watch the 49ers in primetime as much
as we possibly can
so put me down for Jeff grant yeah I
thought about taking them in the second
round they were one of the teams that I
was kind of tossing around to you know
yes Shanahan brings them exciting brand
of football I mean gosh every every time
they were on a primetime game last year
it was lots of big plays and you know
create creativity where you just went
wow that's really cool look at that
router look at that screen or that's a
really cool reverse or play-action pass
whatever it may be and you know yes they
have a little bit of a bull's eye on
them a little bit too to your point I
mean it's they're the NFC champion going
scrutiny or dissection of Jimmy
Garoppolo does make for good primetime
TV it does I mean we all know he's good
you know we just want to see yeah it can
he be great can he bring that team to
another level and then there is a lot of
personalities on that team you know we
got the primetime you know Richard
Sherman or he didn't shake my hand even
though we have 10 different camera
angles that he shook your head you know
whether it's Richard Sherman or Nick
Bose or and they just have a great
energy about them that we got the
witness in person for that divisional
playoff game and we need to have a
camera on the sidelines at all times to
see any interaction between Richard
Sherman and his new teammate Trent
Williams dating back to the game yeah
right where Williams slapped him in the
face right yeah yeah I know yeah that's
that well that'll be fun I mean that'll
be something the locker room will make
fun of and hype up a little bit when
they first walk in there because they
did that was after what the wild card
game and 2000 our game right right and
yeah well it's warm in 2012 but yeah
that'll that'll add some excitement to
the locker room all together but I'm
with you the 49ers is a good one
all right my third one I can't believe
I'm gonna do this but I am because you
know a little bit of like star power
dysfunction you know I'm going with
Cleveland Browns baby believe hland
yes I don't care you know I don't know
how good they're gonna be but I know
they're exciting and the pressures on
Baker Mayfield and Odell Beckham jr. and
Jarvis Landry and you know the last time
they were in prime time last year miles
Garrett was smashing some guy over the
head with a helmet like it was a weapon
so they also had you know the Rams game
debacle at the end of that football game
as far as primetime last year but then
there was the excitement of the Jets
game with obj catches a long touchdown
passes and all that and you know to me
it's just a lot of personalities on this
team and there is legitimate talent and
I think that along with a new coach and
Kevin Stefanski the analytics department
running the football team and the
pressure on I think some of these stars
like Baker Mayfield to be a guy that I
would say has more pressure on them than
just about anybody in football and I
don't think Odell Beckham jr. and Miles
Garrett or far behind and the whole
scope of the league let alone all three
of them being on the same team so III
want to see them do well for Cleveland
and I like those guys and I think it
will be a fun watch you did well with
your first two picks but I'll tell you
what your left one on the board that you
should have taken but by getting greedy
to watch obj and the Browns how can you
not want to see maximum games involving
Drew Brees in his last season in the NFL
and everything else that goes along with
the Saints there's something magical
about those games that are broadcast out
of the Superdome the feel the lights the
fans hopefully the fans will be there
Sean Payton's offenses Taysom Hill with
the change of pace I just I think the
Saints Saints bucks in primetime
maybe Saints bucks in primetime twice
you know Cowboys Giants is always a game
that there's a lot of push and pull and
the network's want that game I think
this year the Saints Bucs games there's
gonna there's probably been a lot of
discussion behind the curtain about who
wants what game when it comes down to
Saints bucks
but it'd be great to see both of those
games in primetime it would be yeah I
would love to raisin I know I know I did
I know I mean there's no disrespect we
both left our guns on the board they're
exciting I want to see Buccaneer Saints
one of those prime time games or if it's
only one I want to see it later in the
year because I'm really rooting for
Brady and Brees to be like neck and neck
with the all-time touchdown conversation
and kind of see who ends up on top
because again I know we know what's true
breezes last year we think Tom Brady is
fighting for two more years but I still
think there's a good chance Tom Brady
could end this year and go okay I'm done
see you guys later so I know we met we
will be left Lamar Jackson on the board
and the Ravens as exciting as they were
on primetime football we probably messed
up as far as that's concerned I blame
that on you know I I yeah I look there's
only six spots in the draft here's the
bottom line there are plenty of great
teams in the NFL right now there are
plenty of great potential prime time
games issue we left off the calendar I
left off the Vikings by design because
we know what happens when they play in
primetime
Seahawks we didn't mentioned this I
almost took the Seahawks in round 3 the
see our own game to a fun team to watch
me play you want to see them play you
want to be able to study them watch
their teams and enjoy those games and
stand alone and here's the thing if the
NFL ends up backfilling Saturday if
there isn't college football we're gonna
have some standalone games that slide
into Saturday maybe some of these great
quarterbacks and great teams that we
don't see in primetime we'll see in
standalone Saturday games if there is in
college football but hopefully there
will be college foot
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports